it's an awesome feeling isn't it playing
a really great game in an industry and
community where we all love a bit of
healthy discourse of a console
preference game preference or weather
flappy bird is technically a game it is
I think I finally found the one thing we
can all agree on we all love the feeling
of playing a great game so this week on
reality check we're gonna celebrate
great games by delving into the
psychology of the feeling and see if we
can shed some lights on our developers
make it happen
[Music]
you know that moment when you're playing
a really great game and you you kind of
just get into the zone you lose all
track of time hours pass by without
notice until suddenly it's dark outside
you've missed this week's game of
Thrones nuclear war has engulfed the
planet and oh bloody hell you forgot to
feed mittens
well psychologists have a name for this
kind of state it's called cognitive flow
to you and me this could be called being
on fire or in the zone technically
speaking is defined as a mental state of
being completely immersed in a feeling
of energized focus with full involvement
and enjoyment in the process of the
activity according to the hungarian
psychology professor who first proposed
the idea in 1970 flow as it can be
simply known is essentially completely
focused motivation and occurs because
all of your attention is on the task at
hand
there is simply no more attention left
for anything else as a result of all
this flow players experience spontaneous
happiness and this helps maintain an
enjoyable experience which in turn
increases motivation and draws players
to continue playing other components of
a flow experience are emerging of
actions and awareness a loss of the true
passage of time an improved performance
and experiencing the activity as
intrinsically rewarding think back to
the last time you had a truly great game
playing experience now I bet my house
the you were experiencing flow so then
helping us players to experience the
state is pretty much the goal of every
video game developer even if they might
not know it okay let's get tentacle so
what does a task or in our case a game
need to do to get players experiencing
cognitive flow well there are three
things broadly speaking required to get
a player in the zone the game must have
clear goals and direction in other words
you must know what it is that you have
to do or can do next
now I'm sure we've all experienced
moments of the opposite of playing game
where you just have no idea where you're
meant to be going next this can be
frustrating and importantly flow
breaking
the task must have feedback a crucial
part of maintaining flow in gaming is
being told by the game that you're doing
a good job or a bad job just feedback
that our actions actually matter and are
taking an effect on the world the player
must have confidence that they are
capable of completing the task so the
level of challenge must be appropriate
okay now that last one that balance
between challenge or difficulty level
and skill level is absolutely crucial in
attaining a flow state if a task is too
simple then the player can easily become
bored or apathetic and lose the state of
flow on the other hand if it's too
difficult it can make the player anxious
and frustrated again breaking flow check
out this picture chart now as it
demonstrates flow is at its peak of the
apex of high difficulty and high skill
so a game which trains you well on the
mechanics while deftly increasing the
difficulty level to match should be the
ultimate initiator of flow interestingly
not everyone can experience cognitive
flow with the same level of ease now
this could have something to do with a
separate psychological idea known as the
locus of control this refers to the
extent that an individual believes that
they are in control of events that
affect them
so applied to a video game situation
it's the belief that if you succeed it's
down to your skill and if you fail well
then it's down to your mistakes not an
issue with the game saying now a person
with a high level of internal locus of
control is more likely to believe that
things that happen in their day-to-day
life are to do with their own actions
whereas someone with a high external
locus of control is more inclined to
blame external factors beyond their
influence experimental research is
hinted that people who are more inclined
to believe they're in control their
actions may also be more likely to enter
a flow state when engaged in a task so
in a game situation if a developer can
also help the player feel that in-game
success and failures are due to their
skill then this can only help get them
in the zone for me this is what I like
about the idea of cognitive flow it
makes you think about how different
people can have very different opinions
of the same game for example you know
that discussion where one person says
I love that game and another says really
I'll never really go into it to be
honest now when you consider cognitive
flow you can quickly see how these
different experiences could come about
now as far as I could tell the
importance of flow in gaming while an
interesting notion hasn't actually been
tested empirically however flow itself
is a well-established psychological idea
so let me know what you thought of all
this anyway in the comments down below
or you can reach out to me on Twitter at
cam Fras Rob last week on the show I
explored six exciting alternatives to
oculus rift however one question was
asked which comes up every week without
fail what is the music you use at the
end of the show so get a pen and paper
ready
it's called way up high and you can find
it on the music library audio network
it's a really great tune and I actually
heard it being used in a video
presentation at London's Natural History
Museum the other week so now you know
okay
thanks for watching everybody and see
you back here next week for more science
meets of video games goodness
[Music]
according to me my Hummer Holly Holly
muhuali sis six and oh Jesus muhuali six
and hello Holly Holly Holly Holly going
to my Holly
kiss-kiss sick Kissick sand Holly
six-inch Mohali no 6 and Holly
Mahalo Mahalo according to the Hungarian
psychology professor who first proposed
the idea in 1970